so I let go of my fears and stream
twitch without having my PC anymore you
know I want to do it I'm very nervous
about creative valy the only fear you
have is the fear of being insecure of
people's judgment I give zero [__]
about how many people judge how many
people are watching right now cuz it's a
new medium with a lot of friction for my
audience and that's okay I was streaming
for like 3 years continuously and then I
lost a PC bro you don't need a [__]
PC okay what do you think the PC is
doing for you I just felt like I was
being able to give more value people
were able to see like documents that I
would read over I would be able to how
much does a PC cost between 25 and 3500
great I'm going to buy you one right
now no way attention is the number one
asset welcome thank you for joining me
for this live stream I'm incredibly
excited to be with all of you let's just
like let's not waste any time especially
because I'm 11 minutes late let's get
right into the show show Q&A time let's
rock and roll team send someone up here
we
go I cannot hear our friend yo yo yo yo
yo what's going on Gary team friends
how's it going thank you go can you hear
me I can brother what's your name nice
epic Smasher or Timothy Timothy yes what
your uh what is your question my friend
this
evening so real quick I my question was
uh should I let go of my fears and
twitch thank you for being on the show
Timothy great contribution yes you
should get rid of your fears fear is
fear is the poison the utter poison of
our society and politicians parents
education systems businesses
bosses and hurt people in your life are
weaponizing fear against all of you to
not do things that will genuinely make
you
happy but what's your actual question
cool cool no no I like it I like it it's
so true and and what you what you do for
one of us you you you do for so many so
I I really appreciate for for what you
do um so should I let go of my fears and
stream twitch without having my PC
anymore uh you know I want to do it I'm
very nervous I want to create I want to
be a
to to stream on the PC or stream on
mobile or my phone with creating value
and I I'm just nervous about creating
value of course you should look I've
promoted this I'm Gary ve with 40
million social media followers there's
only 500 people on here I'm not scared
that somebody's gonna tune in and be
like yo why doesn't he have 40,000
people like to me at where I am my
career 512 people right now is like
having one person
on the only fear you have is the fear of
being insecure of people's judgment I
give zero
[__] about how many people judge how
many people are watching right now
because it's a new medium with a lot of
friction for my audience and that's okay
like I'm building black block by block
and if I can help one person in this
show you right now to go on the only
thing you fear is having three people
on well I I'm live I got we got five at
the moment got five at the moment which
I'm really stoked I used to I was
streaming for like three years
continuously and then I lost a PC and
yeah bro you don't need a [__]
PC okay what do you think the PC is
doing for you I just felt like I was I
was being able to give more value people
were able to see like documents they
were like that I would read over I would
be able to show them crypto i' a do not
do not do you not have do you not have
the money for a new
pc not at the moment my funds are
allocated respect how much does a PC
cost a operating one between 25 and 3500
great I'm gonna buy you one right
now no
yes no I assume the team has your
information send me a link to what you
want and where you want me to send it
and I will buy you a$ 25 to
$3500 personal computer tonight right
here on the spot to eliminate the excuse
of the PC of what is holding you back no
way yes way yeah wow wow oh my gosh I'm
shocked I thank you so much I once again
you helped so many individuals and and
just by you asking this this question or
just by you answering this question it's
gonna help out so many people well also
the [__] $3,500 PC is gonna also
help bro what do you think we're gonna
come on this night this special night of
Q&A streaming and not [__] set the
[__] tone to have a good night we're
buying you PC
bro wow wow dude oh my gosh bro let's
go team let's get his info you'll send a
link you got it get have him email you
the link to the exact computer he wants
and I'll take care the rest no way yes
way BR get off the show we got too many
people that [__] answer love
accomplished you don't even have to
debate if it needs to be on a phone or
PC you just got a free [__] PC it's
straight up straight up thank you thank
you so much I appreciate it so much
you're
welcome all of you on Instagram you
better get the [__] twitch.tv Gary V
right now because you can't get on the
show bullshitting on [__] Instagram
get over to Twitch right now stop
[__] around you're not even seeing
the whole [__] scene you should see
the chat I don't want to [__] hear I
don't have twitch it's called go to the
[__] App Store and download twitch
and create a [__] [__] username Ally
scary
yes Al you have a lot of clothes I do
it's called Allie's closet I love it
good for you hey thank you um you have
inspired oh real quick Ally I apologize
for how do people get on the show they
leave they leave exciting comments here
if you see something that you like tell
them to send the message AKA whisper to
team Gary ve okay so if I like
something so everyone's gonna say I have
a question colen and their question yeah
Abby's gonna watch the questions for me
because I'm focused on Ally and
everybody on yeah so from now on all now
we got a thousand the thousand people
that are on if they want to ask a
question they'll say I have a question
colon then they'll ask her a question
hashtag I have a question colon then
they'll ask the
question the Carly Abby you like you'll
pay attention you'll as I'm talking to
people you'll say I got a question for
you I'll be like what I'll tell tell you
if I like it you have a sense of me okay
then we'll throw them in fair enough
Ally Gary all right so um five years ago
you inspired me to take a leap of faith
and build my own business um I 10ex exit
um from a Facebook group to um what I
now have and have been running for the
last year which is Ali's closet. store
um where I buy and resell Patagonia
Northface Lululemon and viori we grew
like 30,000 followers on the Facebook
group and since Facebook groups like
lack of efficiency and sustainability
like it was really hard work I was my
husband was more like my roommate and
not not my husband so I was like I got
to change it so last year I built a
website um last it'll be the anniversary
on the 21st of February um and I'm
running into some problems I am um
finally plateauing um and my net profits
are going down like 30% a month um I've
tried
um doing what you suggest the posting
multiple times on I've got my checklist
Facebook are you on Tik Tok live and
doing Tik Tock shop I can't do Tik Tock
shop because I have name brands like
Patagonia Northface and Lulu but um I
just for the first time have my Tik Tok
reach like 50,000 views on one of my
videos um so I hear racking your brain I
I want you to go on Tik Tock live Tik
Tock live is one of the great
opportunities right now pushing hard and
only a thousand people are on right now
okay if I went on Tik Tok live right now
in 15 minutes I'd have a thousand people
on and 80% of them would not even know
who the [__] I am because Instagram when
you go live like I just did right now I
have 567 people on Instagram live I'm
about to hang up on them so they go to
Twitch so Instagram get your [__]
together go to twitch.tv garyb if I went
on Tik Tok I would start with 300 when
you go live on Instagram they hit up all
your followers so right away I get
2,000 and then it goes down to 600 like
it is right now on
Instagram I go on and it starts putting
my live into peoples for
you and so if I'm on for an hour or two
I'll look up and I'll have 2,000 people
80% of which don't know me everyone's
job here is to get discovered why would
you want something to go viral because
more people find out about you yeah the
number one way to get discovered right
now is Tik Tock live I want you to go
Tik Tock live and entertain people you
don't even have to do full integration
on Tik Tok shop Tik Tock live not Tik
Tock posts Tik Tock live I want you to
go live and I want you to go live for
three hours a day okay figure it the
[__]
out I'll have to quit my part-time
teaching job well respect on that so you
have that so give me an hour a day okay
an hour a day where you go on live and
you do your [__] thing and I see tfam
tv4 say holy [__] three hours when I say
three hours or I say 50 pieces of
content a day I'm just saying as many as
you can Ally I've started to notice that
I have pet
muscles why did this happen because a
year ago I decided I was going to do 100
push-ups a day no matter what even if I
was in a gym or when I was traveling and
because I did it I'm seeing visual
response had I not done it I
wouldn't if if you put in an hour of Tik
Tok live you're going to get an hour of
Tik Tock live results if you put two
hours of Tik Tok live you'll get two
hours of Tik Tok live results but Tik
Tock live right now is what everybody
follows me for which is insights to
where's the Arbitrage of opportunity by
the way for all 10,000 of you right now
I expect all of you to share this link
in your family group chat on Twitter in
your Discord please share this link
right now and say you're [__] missing
it Gary is giving out gems for
free by the way if you have a question
for me and you want to be on the show
right now hash leave a comment in twitch
hash I have a question colon and then
ask for a question the team's looking
for it and we'll pick best questions Ali
Tik Tok live is gonna grow you oh thank
you guys and yes Alice's closet we beat
North pH for nude Patagonia warn Weare
and Lulu like new and we make Su
sustainable shopping as fun as we can so
thank you so much Gary the plug at the
end I'm pressed Al let's move it on it's
in my to SS Stout 123 first time chatter
big shout out to
gamer odz first time chatter by the way
there's a thousand people in here that
are getting ads a tier one sub gets you
out of ABS ads excuse me not ABS I'm
looking for abs I know that a lot of you
buy gifted subscriptions on Twitch who
who's generous tonight and wants to gift
some subs to the Thousand here that are
going to be hanging out with us and they
may miss the best part of my
answer because a [__] ad pops up
Dustin that's what they said before
today and so I think some like I think
some of the ogs need to jump in here I
just bought a $3,500 computer I think
some people in here could buy a [__]
subscription who's feeling super gifty
oh Bryson's about to raid let's go is
Bryson raiding I think did oh I love a
Bryson raid all right let's do
it Bryson raid I see it now it's coming
in it feels like oh we're here big shout
out to [__] Bryson Vader Sports
[__] g g Andre how's it good too
good I feel like I'm a little concerned
Andre I think I'm enjoying this way too
much in the first 20 minutes and I have
a feeling my evenings and mornings are
vulnerable because I feel like I'm going
to do this a lot especially when people
raid me when I get [__] raided I get
really crazy yeah I'm gonna be
vulnerable now too my heart is
racing here so much for me your question
let's do it uh I'm Andre based in the UK
um I run my own startup and have been
for the last seven years alongside
full-time work it's been intense I've
sacrificed a lot um I gave up that job
not that job the startup I paused it
last year because I kind of got head
hunted for a role to do the same thing
they could they couldn't say no to was
paying you a lot
more yeah yeah how old are you uh 32
amazing so you're a
child absolutely so yeah I I put that on
pause wanted to throw myself into this
new role um so I work in a university in
the UK um and I promote mental physical
and social health um that's what I've
been doing my startup and I wanted to
bring everything that learned from
yourself and from running my business
into that so I spent a few months
building up a proposal around a new
social media presence um and the things
we could do with that to improve student
well-being overall and because my kind
of service has no marketing
professionals it's really difficult to
explain the impact of value driven
content and what and different social
media channels so um that proposal
actually got rejected and I'm stuck I
can't use social media so my question to
you is I'm in it for the long run I want
to do this Justice if you couldn't use
social media how would you engage with
Generation
Z that's like asking me if I couldn't
drink water how would I fulfill my
thirst how the [__] are you gonna reach
gen Z without [__] social
media tell me about it I tried hard
three months to put into a proposal and
got rejected I stumped for months so now
the question becomes you decide to just
[__] it because the pay is worth it
for you right now like a lot in the
seven years so um stability is important
to me now correct don't this I'm about
to go there don't judge
yourself just do this for a couple like
bro I was when I was 32 ask me ask me
what I was doing when I was
32 what were you doing the 32 I was
stocking shelves in the liquor
store do not beat yourself up if you
need three or four years for the
financial stability that the job is
currently doing for you on the flip
side understand that I don't have a
[__] answer for you when it's
impossible to achieve the
goal that's nuts because I've been
stuned I I didn't know what to do it's
okay to realiz don't live life
fake I know you talk about like social
media for went
yesterday what would you do in that
scenario I'm looking one more time
brother you so a lot about if social
media went down this like yesterday well
the problem is if social media got
banned around the world right now all of
gen Z and gen Alpha and Gen X and
Millennials and Boomers would have to go
somewhere like you saying let's all make
pretend it all went away well we'd all
watch television and listen to Spotify
and like like we'd have to do
something that's not the situation
you're in social media has not gone away
and you're trying to reach gen Z and
they only live on social
media so in what you're doing is playing
a fake game I would run pre-rolls on
YouTube I'd run pre-roll ad videos on
YouTube funny should say that I can only
have an unlisted YouTube yeah it sounds
like you work at a [__] [__]
place yeah large organizations realize
now they're hard to no [__] I run a
[__] Ad Agency that works with only
large organizations and they're [__]
struggling with relevance because they
live in [__]
yesterday but that doesn't mean you
should beat yourself up and think you're
a bad man for the next three years while
you collect that paycheck and you just
make the most out of like your dog [__]
situation so keep fighting until I don't
have to I can move on you got to keep
overc communicating that there is no way
to reach gen Z outside
of I mean gen Z doesn't even [__] use
Google for search to use Tik Tok what
the [__] am I supposed to
do
all right that
helps here's why it should help if you
leave this call not beating yourself up
and playing some sort of fake game like
there's some
answer and if you don't beat yourself up
for being okay for working here for
three years to collect a paycheck
because you need to save some money for
stability and then you can do your next
thing then you've left here in a good
[__]
game to be honest you taught me that
perspective for a long time now which is
why I'm still in the same role and I
haven't left I'm proud of you me so
thank you very much for that game
appreciate who's
next yo who's what's up brother what's
your name Andy gillers slea how are you
doing Andy it is such a [__] player
pleasure pleasure you're a player too
you look like a player so I'm out here
in uh in heon Spain I uh I went to The
Culinary Institute of America in New
York but I switched careers like I
graduated C Institute in my early 30s um
and I moved out here with my wife and
you know we got residency which is
lovely and uh you know in the meantime I
kind of had to do some Consulting work
which ended up kind of becoming a
fulltime gig with recipe writing and uh
creating content for like newsletters
and things like that uh which I really
really love and also doing some you know
videos on Tik Tok uh and I love your
messaging with social media
I guess one of my questions
was do you think as someone that's
either a consultant or someone that's
you know uh uh someone that's providing
a good or a service do you think it's
important to give away some of your
content for free when you're starting
out whether it is a as much as humanly
possible yeah
gotcha advice is not free advice is not
valuable when it's General right bro
there's nothing you would say in the Tik
Tok that somebody else hasn't said
before absolutely now I do mostly
cooking videos I don't give a [__] I
also have I have 126 followers you know
this is that's better than zero yeah
sure give away everything as humanly
possible for free that is what I do look
what the do you understand what I'm
doing right now dude this is amazing
this is uh this is absolutely incredible
it's like like I have a company that
like there's clients that pay like
$150,000 per hour my time I'm just
sitting here doing like I get give it
away for free bro it's how you get love
it's how you bring
value totally yeah yeah give as much as
you can bro gotcha I love you good luck
thank you so much yeah let me know if
you're in New York I'm like hitting up
all these food influencers yesterday on
Instagram at like midnight to come to
Little
Maven New York you
gotta what BR let's like drink some
wines like let's you know check out
alinos and like bring some real [__]
Spanish [__] ham too yeah no we're
doing hamon beo all day let's [__] go
yeah seriously bring it I got real I got
real rioa that I'll never get to without
it so come dude when year around check
it out yeah I will thank you bro yeah uh
everybody's watching if you have a
question you want to be on the show put
in the twitch chat hash I have a
question colon and a question ladies
anything stand out for you yet do you
want to have a mentalist or magician
read your M
no he or she can have their own channel
for that I want real questions from real
people that I want to really [__] Sol
for all right all right keep looking the
questions are gonna come in now let's
get to our next question these hats I'm
bringing tonight that nobody's gonna be
able to get because there's such a
limited run it's gonna be a [__]
thing this ambitious angel look at that
[__]
angel look at this [__] ambitious
Amalia Amil you're on mute
baby I'm I'm sorry I apologize I'm all
right I'm just I can how are you I'm
just so excited to meet you I've been um
I went to the piecon and I thought that
I was going to be able to see you but
you wasn't there but it was still a
pleasure to see oh yeah Philly I'm so
sorry I know there was mix up where they
put up the ads for a day and made people
feel like I was gonna be there I I
texted wallow I'm like yo don't [__] me
up yeah it it was really dope though
very very I was sitting in the front I
was willing y definitely I was just
coming to um get some type of like
information from you um I was looking
into like starting a podcast of my own
um I'm working a part-time job right now
and um I'm just like every day waking up
thinking about start in my own podcast
it's been like for the last three and a
half years but I'm at work what you
thinking
about how to start do you know what to
do like do you have the general basics
of like how do you record an audio how
uploaded to Spotify and apple do you
have that sense no I don't I'm just like
putting one foot in front of the other
as of right now yeah no worries that's
why I'm here I'm here for this reason
literally go to literally go to Google
after tonight and type in how do I
upload an audio file all right to a
podcast okay the amazing thing about
Google and YouTube is it's there for all
of us at 101 okay you know like for some
people like I realize that like my soas
hurt yeah that's like a muscle right so
I was like how do I stretch my so ass
enter I didn't know okay and you don't
know how to do a podcast good news
literally type in in YouTube and Andor
Google maybe you read better I'm more
audio and video yes so more audio and
video go to YouTube if you're more
reading go into Google and type in how
do I
upload an audio file for a podcast how
do I post my first episode of a podcast
whatever your question is it will show
you the answer okay that's it all right
and how did you get comfortable like I'm
so like because I don't give about
people making fun me I'm I'm I'm and
it's crazy for me like I'm the opposite
like I feel like I can do like public
speaking I can talk up talk to anyone I
come across like daily even at work at
home people calling my phone or I'm at
work people like talking to me on like
casual conversations but it just be like
basic but then it goes into them telling
me like personal business
think that makes people feel warm to you
right right so then I think in the back
of my head like wow this person is
telling me their personal business but I
can do this in person but far as like
recording I really get like stuck
whereas though I'm like uh what do I do
now what do I say now what do I say next
things like that just ask questions okay
how you feeling what's wrong what's on
your mind okay when you feel stuck as a
podcast host ask questions ask basic
questions okay what most upsets you what
[__] you up the most okay what are you
about okay what's on your mind that's it
okay I I think I think it's a different
thing I think you're worried about the
Judgment most people don't start because
they worry about
judgment you can say that yes for me yes
you know what I mean darl honestly
here's my thing on that like who gives a
[__] right winners don't judge because
they're worried about their [__] and
losers judge and what the [__] are you
worried about losers for
right winners don't judge I'm not
spending time worried about you doing
well on your podcast okay losers who
have misery loves
company they're the ones that are going
to tell you your podcast sucks because
they got
time to tell you that to tell you I
ain't got time to tell you I'm wi it
yeah I'm busy
exactly people are out here not living
dreams because they're worried about
other people who are losing judging them
right we need to get off that
[__] I think that's my fear 100% And you
know the problem is the people we're
most worried about is the people in our
[__] family right absolutely your
uncle your mama your brother like [__]
yes and I'm the youngest of six so yeah
those five above you got [__] things
to say yeah you're absolutely right my
big thing is like yo [__] you big
[Laughter]
bro I'm living my life why don't you
worry about your [__] why can't you keep
a job [__] don't worry about my
podcast [__] absolutely
absolutely one more question before I
end it with you um how do I look for
like I've been on Amazon as well looking
for like podcast equipment do you know
like the best brand to like invested I'm
sorry on what on What on Amazon um like
podcast equipment do you know like best
bra to like invest in equip equipment is
[__] okay okay period I know my
team's got stuff I [__] did I had no
lighting I had no mics I did a thousand
episodes of Wine Library TV in my
daddy's [__] liquor store I had no
[__] equipment I had a $300 [__]
camera from Best [__] buy okay
equipment is another
excuse to not to not that's it be I love
you for that period
equipment is the cliche excuse to not
start I don't know how is the other one
it's called Google right the thing
that's stopping you is your five
siblings your mom your dad your plus one
your kids like people people
period when someone says yo why you
wasting your time with that podcast
ain't no one listening anyway you look
them dead in the face and says my
podcast has nothing to do with your
[__] life right [__] you
absolutely I thank you so much for this
and I'm so so so happy I got to talk to
you I'm happy we got to talk to who this
what I'm doing tonight tonight's a good
night for me too I love all of you I
wish I could thousand of you get to who
we can let's keep it going we'll talk
let's get to the next question you want
be have anything you like bye bye D yeah
this is a good one um how do you hold
space for people vending to you about
their problems without their problems
affecting your mood beautiful get that
person in the [__] getto who is that
Kiara Kiara you're about to come on the
show all give me one before Kiara and
then Kiara's
next PR King of Hearts what's good my
guy yo PR the King of Hearts what's
good
we're GNA move on to next one we'll get
somebody El sorry
PR he h had all that equipment [__]
doesn't [__] work coach a what's good
y Gary man first and foremost man I got
to give you your flowers man I mean
honestly I learned so much from you over
the years um you know I'm a professional
boxing coach I've been working with
professional fighters MMA fighters UFC
fighters everything but then I also went
ahead and moved it online um and I have
a YouTube channel I do all that stuff
online now and a lot of stuff that I do
from Instagram and all that is from
learning basically by trying to mirror
and mimic what I see you doing I mean
that's as basic as I can get I said bro
I read I get a thousand these DMS a
month I say it all the time watch what
I'm doing I'm focused on live right now
you should be focused on live I'm
focused on [__] LinkedIn you should
like it's thank you for saying that it's
my greatest joy watching people follow
my moves and get their [__] you know
get their wins from it real quick though
I apolog there's a hype train there's
also people asking for Subs because
people are [__] up with these ads I I
I saw I saw Pok scoot get in there and
give some who's at the top of the list
Ginger's giving some subs I we need some
[__] we need gifted Subs in here go
ahead coach it's crazy it's crazy
because I've been around you know some
of the you know High highly talented
athletes I'm I'm freaking Star Struck
talking to you man it's crazy man how
much I respect you man but um thank you
right all right a couple of things man
real quick man um you know I see that
you're you're pushing over to Twitch I
see that you're you're pushing over to
Twitch you know I do obviously on
Instagram I could teach instructionals
teach people how to slip jab jab jab
right hook
right I could do all that stuff on on
Twitch I mean on on Tik Tok I could do
that on Instagram YouTube shorts but I
see the the push to Twitch I think live
streaming is where social media was 10
years ago 10 years ago 20 14 social
media was already known it had come out
for like seven years but people were
underestimating how big it was GNA be I
was on Twitch when it was Justin.tv
I've done live when it was on Ustream
but I feel like we're in this moment
where we're on the preice of many
different ways of being on live right
meaning I feel like I for example for
everybody's tuned in I'm here every day
that I'm in the office and we're live in
theice office and I'm unmuting and
talking to you on mute all thousand of
you I expect you here tomorrow let's
hang out work with me this is like my
big new genre the work with me behind
the scenes just come and hang with me
while I'm in the office video game
players streamers like C you know like
all those people like Aiden Ross all
that like that genre is known but a
businessman that's really running a $400
million company with 2,000 employees
just chilling in his office taking
meetings all day people don't think
that's right just like people didn't
think you could do anything
besides Tik Tock dancing if you're on
Tik Tok but I was telling everybody no
you can do other [__] I think all of us
can be live doing whatever the [__] we
do I believe one of the most famous
people in America could be a gardener
who's just live
gardening so
like I'm sorry I'm sorry go ahead no no
I'm sorry go ahead no I'm just saying so
so for instance like me let's just say
say I'm not um coaching a fighter or
something like that I decid to go live
on Twitch like what like how would you
like if you were a boxing coach how
would you approach the whole twitch
thing because I understand on Instagram
you can go live Tik Tok you can go live
YouTube you can go live how would you
first of all twitch is hard Tik Tock is
the
opportunity okay Tik Tok live is just
gonna put you in front of people and I
would just look at the camera and
talk
okay all right um TI different you got
understand Tik tok's different than
everything because the longer you're on
live the more they're going to put you
in people's streams to discover you no
other platforms doing that so Tik Tok I
notic it it goes up slow right Tik Tok
goes up slow because I've been on Tik
Tok where I feel like nobody's there and
then out of nowhere like people start
showing up is that just how that
algorithm works it's just yes the
biggest reason at zero for five minutes
and then out of nowhere it'll just pop
in well maybe not you wouldn't know but
I know no I know too bro I know that
there's only 568 people on my Instagram
right this second and there was 2,000
the second I went live it goes down
because it pings your users and then
goes down Tik Tock the longer you're on
the more they're putting you in random
people's for you page and you get
discovered so you would just go live big
shout out to Wes Martin who just said
who's this guy I don't know if he's
talking about me or you but we're just
some dudes Wes thank you for [__]
being
here yeah
um yeah I mean I I don't really go live
on Tik Tok I've seen you tell the young
lady to to go on there for 3 hours
straight so again you just you just like
it as simple as place the camera up put
in your office whatever you're doing
work listen to music look at the thing
answer boxing questions I don't [__]
know go [__] food shopping and put on
your [__] forehead live is next live
has been going just like social's been
going but it's on I feel like it's not
next like it's not like I'm saying
something nobody's ever heard before I
think Liv's about to
explode I I I I I agree we're tired of
the same [__] Clips on social Liv is
a different
medium now question about stories on
Instagram like uh like a Instagram story
what I'm noticing is I don't know what
gets in front of the in front of my
audience on stories right I'll post
something 5 10,000 views I'll post
something2 200 views is there a strategy
or simple method do you feel that
Instagram pushes stories you need it's
all about compelling [__] the more [__]
you put out that the first 50 people
that see it love it the more likely
you're going to reach more people okay
so that if not that many people saw it
it's because they just
didn't because the first hundred people
that saw it thought it was whack got it
all right fair enough good get I got
bounce one thing man one thing I'm in
Jersey man can I can I can I get you
boxing session can I give you a boxing
session man you might be able to send me
an email Gary at bner media come on man
let me train you man I'm in Jersey I'm
in Cherry Hill dude you're not in Jersey
you're in [__] Philly that's 100
years from [__] Jersey Cherry Hills
[__] Philadelphia
[__] hours I'm from I'm from New
York City though I just live here don't
K that Jersey [__] you're [__] Philly
bro I know Jerry Hill all right thank
you Gary we'll talk
soon all right who we got who just came
up brand new to Twitch thanks for Gary
mocktail let's go mocktail mom is in the
building let's clap it up for mocktail
Mom Emily how are you oh my gosh I'm
great how are you Gary I'm well fire
away yeah so what are the three top
qualities that you look for in a person
professionally and then also just with
friendships I think empathy is the first
thing I'm most attractive to does one
have the capacity to care about other
people it's huge for me um two I'm a
very big fan of
optimism I am shocked how many people
think this glass is
empty do you know how many [__]
people I know think this glass is
empty and then
meanwhile
me do are you okay was that a good one
was that so good that your
phone
it's actually propped up on a base of my
mom's uh for when she was alive and it
just the phone just slid so sorry about
that was your mom a big fan of
optimism no
clearly I'm trying to honor her because
she's not here anymore but respect I'm
jumping in and making it easy for her
look I I'll go I'll be vulnerable and
talk about my mom if there was one drop
of water in here she would be optimistic
and my father who's changed a lot in the
last decade but 20 years ago this full
cup he would find reason of what's wrong
in between this tippy top and this part
so I'm very big on empathy I'm
incredibly big on optimism the thing
that I'm most visceral to is all the
people in the chat here big shout out to
scuba steve who just bought a bunch of
tier one Subs the people here who are
cynical
by default pessimistic by default
because they're emotionally not strong
and it's easier to be that way I
struggle with that so I need
optimism I need
empathy and I would say the third thing
that I really appreciate is
accountability I think that way too many
people in the world right now are
pointing figures on blaming people it's
my mom's fault it's my dad's fault it's
my ex-husband's fault it's my ex-wife's
fault it's my brother's fault it's my
sister 's fault it's my boss's fault
it's Biden's fault it's Trump's fault
like it's the media's fault it's social
media's fault everything is everybody's
gotten addicted to pointing fingers we
completely lack
accountability and so for me it's
empathy it's optimism and it's
accountability well I just thank you so
much for the level of kindness and
empathy that you do have for people all
over the world it has really touched my
heart for years and I just want to thank
you because that to me is what's most
important you know I'm raising my
8-year-old son Cody and that's what I
instill in him every day is just to be
as loving and kind as he can be to all
people no matter what they're doing in
life and what their spiritual beliefs
are and my biggest dream was to become a
mom and I told my son on the way to
school today your story about your jets
Jersey how your mom made you one my son
didn't know who you were until this
morning I had you on in my car taking
him to school and I told him about it
and his whole face lit up I told him the
exact story about how your mom knitted
you that when you were young and you
guys were poor and that you wanted to
buy the New York Jets so you could put
in the plaque you know coming from a
little boy that you know his momy buying
it yeah and it
just first of you are the human that I
most admire I don't give a [__] about
Jeff Bezos or Steve Jobs or Gary
vaynerchuk the person I most look up to
is the mom or dad whose number one goal
was to only be a mom or dad I am the
byproduct of a woman whose singular goal
in life was to be the best mother she
could be and there's nothing I admired
no athlete no Aaron roggers no you know
Brunson no no Novak jokovic there's no
there's no Martin Luther King there's no
Gandhi and there's definitely no
business person no nobody who made money
that is remotely close to me for the
admiration I have for you and tomorrow
vaynerchuk and all the other mom and
dads out there whose singular
ambition was to be a mom or dad I
couldn't admire it
more that's amazing thank you so much
you know I'm so grateful for you Gary
and your heart this is you know one of
the biggest honors uh of my life is to
be able to meet people like you because
this world needs people that lead with
empathy and kindness and I heard about
your empathy wines years ago so I
started the hashtag em Emily empathy
because of that and I
just I really my deepest prayer for this
world is unity
and that we have more people like you
that lead way that you do we have so
much unity and the media and social Med
like people don't get it Emily good news
the world is more unified Than People
realize of course we have differences
news alert we've had differences forever
there's been World
Wars the the biggest wish I had for
people is for people to get out of the
news Cycles both in Social and
mainstream media and understand how much
Unity we have do you understand how much
love is in this room right now yes
there's unimited [__] love but we've
but people love to sell us on what's not
wrong because we
watch you know you know my favorite part
about this hour and a half is gonna be
that it's an hour and a half that
[__] are not on CNN and Fox
News and [__] are not in their
Facebook feed or Instagram consuming
some [__] [__] negativity
[__]
anyway I got I got rid of my TV years
ago and I don't watch the news I have
one friend and I said if there's
something going on in the world that I
need to know please let me know but I
refuse to watch it so I love you for
that honestly like it's so crazy like
all we're doing and by the way social
too and by the way for all of you that
are mad at social media unfollow the
people that are pushing negative [__]
content be accountable I don't want to
hear about the algorithm the algorithm
is you you're the [__] algorithm
thank you Emily let's keep it going more
everybody who's on right now let's share
this link I want new people in here and
if you send someone I want them to say
Johnny sent me or [__] let me get
some names in here you know like [__]
haunted house sent me horse whatever
Israel 11 sent me [__] twins sent me
sweet dabs sent me let's keep asking the
questions let's keep answering PR King
of Hearts ready there we go bro there we
go deck gu PR King what's good what's
going on Gary how you doing good bro
where you at uh Long Island New York my
man yes yes yes um all right so I'm 34
years old I'm a single father of two uh
my name is Gilberto but I go by PR the
King of Hearts on social media uh real
quick um background so you have an idea
where I'm coming from I was focused on
being an independent music artist I
started focusing on saving up money to
build a home recording studio to start
doing projects covid hit no one can come
anywhere near anyone so I decided to
Pivot and turn my project which I was
going to call clocking out into an
actual brand and I made it a podcast I
used all my recording stuff uh to
basically use for streaming and I've
been trying to work on just building a
brand of focusing on people that want to
clock out of their nine-to-five jobs
that they really have no interest in and
just try to uh build something from
nothing uh that's focused on what they
actually have a a passion for and that
they're really interested in and I
wanted to ask you what do you do or if
you ever find yourself day dreaming
about the future or putting too much
energy into thinking about how things
are going to end up in the future
that you end up missing all the
beautiful things that life has to offer
in the current present time if you could
give an example of that and what you did
to ground yourself and focus on the
present and and
now um I have the capacity to think
about both I've never struggled with
being so focused on the future that I
[__] ruin the
now because I've also been okay with
working my ass off for two years and not
enjoying the fruits of friendship time
and downtime because I've enjoyed my
process for me working on my missions
has been as exciting as going to Las
Vegas with my
boys so I don't I don't struggle with it
because I'm aware that I signed up for
it gotcha you know what I mean yeah like
the only thing I'm always worried about
is not spending enough time with my
family other than that exactly yeah
that's that's mostly what I'm thinking
about yeah on that bro I'm just willing
to change my mind like my Friday nights
I used to work every night now I don't
my Thursday nights this year I used to
work every night now I don't so if you
re like I'm willing to adjust and
reallocate my time that's it bro that's
all it is I appreciate that don't worry
about yesterday if you feel like you
haven't spent enough time with those two
little ones or your brother or your
uncle or whatever fix it tomorrow you're
right the biggest problem in the world
bro is people
dwell yeah there's no [__] time
machine that's that's my issue it's over
of course it's your issue it's
everyone's issue exactly do you know how
insane dwelling
is people dwell like they [__] think
there's a time
machine you're right the [__] are we
dwelling about exactly yeah if you're
dwelling you're [__] up today because
you're mad about yesterday yep you
literally [__] up today on some [__]
about being upset about [__] up
yesterday
M yeah you're completely right learn
from your dwelling and stop that [__] be
accountable I [__] up I was too hungry
for the money I wanted the fame I didn't
worried about Little GTO I don't [__]
know it's okay we all [__] up [__] I
made 19 trillion
mistakes I'm not out here mad at myself
I love myself I'm a human being show me
the [__] human being that didn't make
a thousand [__]
mistakes true just about learning from
them yeah the problem is we put
everybody else on a pedestal and we [__]
on ourselves exactly yeah that's that's
the problem I'm telling all 10,000 of
you right now don't put me on a [__]
pedestal I'm feeling good about myself
I'm a nice guy I'm capable I got love
I'm funny I work hard I got stuff but
like [__] me don't put me on a [__]
pedestal put yourself on a pedestal
exactly thanks bar I really appreciate
that thanks for the time I love you bro
time for a commercial pre-order meet me
in the middle meet me in the middle my
new kids book I expect all 10,000 of you
to order this [__] right now meet me in
the middle my new kids book coming out
this spring this [__] vriends book is
[__] crazy if you have a two to
eighty old in your life this thing is
gonna [__] kill I want links right
now and if you ordered more than five
copies leave a comment right now just
bought five five is my favorite number
meet me in the middle right now
pre-order it don't [__] around the best
kids book ever made in the history of
all time according to tamarrow
vaynerchuck my
mother is available on pre-order right
now links are in there right now I see
the links if you've already pre-ordered
it said been pre-ordered it I've been
pre-ordered it put that in there if
you're pre-ordering it right now say
doing it now if you bought more than
five say five Club in
here get it on [__]
Amazon meet me in the [__] [__]
middle patient Pig and eager Eagle this
book is going to [__] kill it's going
to teach kids to find the middle too
many of these kids go to left or two
right two blue or two red because all of
you are going crazy and going too far
also probably more important for all of
you this is coming out also new book
coming out day trading attention how to
actually build brand and sales in new
social media world I'm predicting now
one of my most commercially successful
books of all time every one of you
should get this book that's available as
well link that up also flexing these new
hats pretty
proper there's this one they've seen
this one but they haven't seen it with
this they've seen this one but they
haven't seen the [__] new updated
version The Fearless [__] ferry in
your mouth these these hats are about to
become a thing most of them I'm giving
away to like super bougie [__]
ridiculously cool sexy [__] cool
[__] [__] influencers so
everyone's going to want it that's why I
didn't get one no that's why you got one
you see your desk it's right your desk
right now oh really yeah bro you're the
ultimate [__] influencer Dustin
[__] let's keep going this is
Kier the one you called out on the chat
do
it K what's
good what's up man what's good just
chilling bro uh yo I can't believe I'm
on the [__] show hell yeah you're on
the [__] show this is [__] crazy
um so yeah I just have a question about
like um how do you hold space for people
that are not necessarily in a good place
and they're like just venting to you
whether that's friends co-workers just
random people off the street um they're
just they're explaining themselves but
then like a part of me I feel bad and
they kind of like it's like an energy
drainer like throughout my day and
because I'm thinking about their
shortcoming I'm like [__] there's
nothing I can do about it like like how
do you how do you deal with people like
venting and complaining to you like can
I give you can I give you can I give you
a huge idea heck
yeah do you have a Tik Tok I do I want
you to make a Tik Tok at the end of the
day okay and I want you to call it
dumping the
bucket okay I want you to start a show
on Tik Tok every night every night hell
yeah this is gonna help you and make and
really help you a lot of ways I want you
to start a show a one minute video that
you make every night called dumping the
bucket what's your name again darling my
name is Kiera I want you to call dumping
the bucket with Kier every episode
that's that's crazy I have okay I have a
um a podcast called the onx strong
podcast I'm in the health and fitness
industry so I I give health and fitness
advice to beginners so I guess I can
start start it on my stick with me stick
with me I want you to make a one to two
minute video every night called dumping
the bucket with Kiara and I want you to
say I started this show because Gary B
on Twitch told me to do it okay and I
want you to start every episode with I'm
an empath and I've got room for people
every
day and every night I'm gonna make a
video talking about something I observed
without using people's real names and
I'm gonna dump out what I took
in because I know by me dumping it out
and helping the world it's going to help
me not have it in me anymore and so I'm
going to take someone's anxiety and
negativity and concern I'm going to sit
with it during the day but every night
I'm going to dump it to the world and
I'm hoping that the people I come across
every day that are struggling become an
inspiration and observation for
y'all
wow okay I can do
that what's gonna happen is two things
you're going to get oh do we lose
her damn I feel like we're winning well
let me just tell her repost any yeah
let's let's move on to the next question
but team for everyone kir if you're
watching in case your phone just died
what maybe she went and did it she might
be the biggest she might be the greatest
guest of all time she just doing it um I
believe dumping the bucket as a team
knows here I've been talking [__] for
two months that I'm gonna start a show
called winding down and they all make
fun of me mainly I make fun of myself
that I haven't started yet and what I
want to do is drink a bottle of wine
review it at night and talk about my day
of observations so I'm giving Kiara
similar advice there you are sorry about
that I don't know what just happened my
man no worries my darling I think you're
gonna win twice one you're gonna get
that [__] off you're gonna get that [__]
off your chest two
audience okay I think you got the gist
little wonky I'm gonna ask the team to
move it off I know you got on multiple
things I'm sure something died but you
got the G dang it don't worry you got it
we got plenty of
[__]
um let's go to next question because I
want to get in a bunch more before I get
up all right let's keep it going Izzy
what's good what's going on my man how
we doing where you from I'm in
Massachusetts are you a [__] Patriot
fan uh uh maybe a Jet fan yeah get out
of here go ahead bro no so my question
had to do with uh it was a Snapchat you
did humility practical steps
straightforward on
humility that's a great question it's
complicated here's what I would say
about humility the practical First Steps
is not to take yourself serious bro I've
accomplished a lot and I get a lot of
love and when I tell you I don't think
I'm special I just
don't humility is understanding you
don't need anybody else's
validation
that's an insight to humility people
understand I believe the reason I'm
humble is because I don't need your
cheering or your
booing okay I think most people live
life for outside people's
validation period that's their entire
framework the opposite sex their mom
their dad random people followers that's
why social media worked I knew it was
going to work I knew that people wanted
followers
yeah I definitely struggle with that for
sure bro I'm telling you I'm
appreciative of all the followers
tonight's a special night I'm clearly
going to do this again because does
everybody want me to do this again leave
a comment twitch I feel like this is
something we should be doing but bro
when I tell you with all the accolades
and everything like I just don't think
I'm that special I feel good about
myself when I say I don't think I'm
special I don't think I'm better than
anyone but I think I'm the
best people get confused when they hear
me don't mix self-esteem
with like just because you have
confidence doesn't mean you don't have
humility I have unlimited both right but
I think humility comes from just
realizing I'm gonna die one day and I'm
gonna get my family is GNA really care
given where I'm at in society I'll
probably get a good 24 hours on social
media people will share their favorite
quote and their video when I'm 100 and
they'll be over
okay oh yeah I think people that
struggle with humility or insecure yeah
period Real
Talk Al got your uh your three books
just came in the mail I know you just
did a quick commercial break but I might
as well uh thank you bro have 12 and a
half out there for your fans thank you
bro I love you you have any nieces or
nephews I my nephew was just born two
three months ago actually bro you better
get this [__] for him I'm gonna [__]
lose my mind if you
don't I want this to be the most
successful kids book of all time because
on some real [__] it's teaching people
the middle the middle is Extreme
confidence and extreme humility that's
actually the middle got you dude my
nephew's he's gonna be hooked up I got
you got you love you bro hey love you
too man see you let's keep
it Kevin W Murray in the building from
Tik Tok on Twitch right now I love you I
need all of you from Tik Tok to go over
to Twitch twitch.tv/ garbe get over here
now
now what
is Hi how are you oh my gosh hold on one
second hold on one second somebody just
said humility is overrated I just want
to pull back on that humility is
overrated there he is inner
scorecard I could not disagree more get
his ass on the show pull him in inner
scorecard we come in we're gon debate
this all right Destiny what's good hi um
so nice to finally meet you um I'm
destiny I am the co-founder of diamond
extensions I'm 31 I recently moved from
Charlotte to Jersey City so I'm right
outside of go welcome thank you thank
you um so we launched our business back
in February 2022 and I currently work a
full-time 9 to-5 and I'm completely
burned out at this point um uh just a
lot of the workload overall it's it's
been kind of challenging to say the
least um and so that on top so the job
sucks yeah like I mean I've been in
merchandising for eight years now and I
think I'm just kind of like burnt out
from it um I don't love it as much as I
used to and do you think that's a
product of whom you're working for and
where or just a general overall thing or
do you not
know I would say yeah definitely where
I'm working okay so that's a big mistake
PE people make career
changes without realizing they just
don't like the team they're on football
players don't retire just because
they're on a shitty team that they don't
like the coach they wait out their
contract and they go sign with another
team yeah I mean I will say like I get
to this point like every two years
within my career like I start putting in
like so much effort and then I just get
burned out and so I don't know I'm
definitely trying to like grow the
business at a larger scale so that I can
make it more of my my full-time job like
I would love to just put this as my
full-time job but what is this uh the
diamond extension so we're a online hair
Boutique and so right now we just
strictly Ecommerce and we've been having
some challenges trying to grow it at a
larger scale um with working like 9 to 5
so would just love your advice on tell
me what you're doing from 6 to midnight
real talk don't [__] me Destiny
because I'm gonna get crazy on you okay
full transparency real [__] no
[__] because you're a you're a young
woman and so you gotta you gotta rest
you gotta go out you got to do [__] I
get it but I need to hear your Monday
through Friday no
[__] yeah
so yeah I work 9 to5 and to be honest
like I come home come on here this might
be the only time we ever talk yeah and
I'm G to give you everything I got so
don't come on this [__] show and
[__] me and try to make it look good
tell me the [__] truth like most days
I come home and I'll put additional
hours into work which is why I'm burn
out how of course yeah till like 10 some
nights 11 and by that time like I'm done
I'm tired and what time do you start you
get home at 5:30 you go like like real
talk like real talk I really need to
hear it no I don't leave work until 5:30
it takes me like an hour a little over
an hour to get home so I'll get home
around like 6:30 then what cook cook um
and then I'll log back in I'll log back
in I'll log back in around like 8ish
maybe decompress the music watch some T
whatever yeah I'll put Show on in the
background start it you're look nobody
should be just working yeah and then
so 8 to 10 8 to 11 you're working on the
thing and then you go to sleep and do it
again yeah pretty much and what about
the weekends the weekends is where I
definitely spend a little bit more time
working on the business but I have been
working like additional weekends as well
for like my 9 to5 so that's where
obviously the burnout is coming in and
so I'm trying to find the balance to be
able to you can't quit yet because this
other gig is not paying for your life
exactly
so my point of view is how long you've
been doing the side
thing since 2022 BB 2022 it's a baby
yeah it's it's fairly fairly new yeah
it's a baby yeah two years old is a
baby I know I just want it to grow no
[__] but I don't know if you heard but
two-year-olds [__] their pants
still I mean what will you put it like
that yeah it's it's a baby I'm gonna put
it like that you got a two-year-old
business is a [__] baby it shits its
pants pretty yeah great
analogy good news you're young as
[__] do you understand that yeah yeah do
you I mean I feel like at this is just
not where I saw myself at 31 what the
[__] are you seeing yourself at 31
for I just would was hoping to be a
little bit further along than where I'm
at right now
why because I feel like time is just so
that's all we have and you're gonna live
for 70 more
years you're a 31 year old in 2024 with
modern medicine exploding you're going
to live to
yeah it feels like Tom just it yes watch
this everybody in the chat tell me how
old you are right now tell me how old
you are in the chat right
now and then tell me when you've figured
it
out yes listen you're you're a kid
here's what I'm hearing look at all
these ages like you're just
starting and we're on Twitch look at
these numbers we're supposed to be all
16 but we're not
the problem here is how's the how's the
buiness like in the first two years it
sounds like you got something going a
little something I mean we we've had
some sales but you know I definitely I'm
I want to grow it at a larger scale I
want to see how much how much social
media are you putting out not as much as
I should to be honest I don't post
enough yeah how much how many posts does
your business post a week on social
media don't lie because I'll look it up
and I'll [__] no I'm going to lie
like barely enough like we'll post
during the holidays and that's like it
like I barely have enough like I really
don't have enough time you saw Abby's
face right
now I'm G Tik Tok Abby's face
is they know when I hear when I hear
once a day I'm mad you said we once
posted during Christmas you came on this
[__]
show I'm out here talking about day
trading attention I want you [__]
posting I want your business posting
four to 20 times a day oh my God and you
had the audacity to come on this show
and said we posted on Thanksgiving
once oh I feel blasted um
yeah yeah that's like coming on a show
and be like yo I don't know why I ain't
got a six-pack yet and I'm like cool
let's talk it out how many times have
you done ab exercises and you're like
once but that's the thing like I'm
trying to like balance that in my job
and like trying to find you just sat
here and told me you're [__] on work
three hours a day at night the [__] are
you
doing yeah a lot of people work on side
[__] and they stand in front of the
computer and try to make pretend they're
doing
something a lot of people go to the gym
and [__] go on their phone on the
treadmill and walk at a [__] snail's
pace and watch the [__] Netflix show
and make pretend they went to the gym
for an hour where they didn't break a
[__]
sweat a lot of dudes go in the gym and
start throwing around weights now that
I'm educated big shout out to Mike pante
and Jordan SC I go to an equinox once in
a while because I'm traveling and I see
dudes go for the vanity and start
throwing around weights and [__]
doing curls swinging their whole [__]
body they're not building their [__]
[__] you can't [__] move when you do
your [__] these [__] are like
this and this on some ego [__] they're
in for an
hour they're not accomplishing
anything I'm worried that you're going
on [__] the computer three hours a
night and
bullshitting definitely not that like
I'm so what are you
doing just all of the tasks that I
couldn't get through to out throughout
the day like what um just because before
you say anything ready for this yeah
you're gonna yeah exactly like before
you tell me anything the number one task
for a business that doesn't have enough
customers is to
Market yeah what are we doing if you
don't have customers you have nothing
yeah you're right oh I know yeah I may
not know about a lot of things this
isn't a cooking show this is not a show
about how to get your lawn real green
and healthy this is not a show about how
to make perfect [__] roasted coffee
this a Big Show and that's what I do and
I know I'm right and I want this for you
I'd rather you just relax and enjoy your
[__] evening so you're not burnt out
than to not do the [__] right
strategy on the three [__] hours that
you're on
yeah yeah I think I need
to dedicate more time to like posting on
social media so that we can you maybe
you have to post two posts a day for
your business and post them on Tik Tok
so people discover it because you might
go viral you might get more views
Instagram's hard but you should do it
Facebook's a monster Facebook fan page
you should absolutely do that Pinterest
like you gotta [__] Comm if you're
giving me three hours a night I need an
hour for social okay and before you go
into what next like what do I post you
have a million businesses that are in
your business go look at their
[__] okay you
I can do that I know you know I can see
in your [__]
face I can do that customers what the
[__] are you
doing that's like opening the score
having no customers and fixing the
shelves I know it sucks like nobody
wants a store with no customers well get
some [__]
customers I'm gonna get some
customers good luck thanks Gary I
appreciate
it I got you if you want to be on the
show everybody it's right here on Twitch
I know there's 1400 of you on Tik Tok
proven my point by the way right here
live proven my point started with 50
people on 1,400 can you see it n you
can't really see it
yeah this is what goes on with Tik Tok
as you can see top right corner 1400 are
on right now I just looked over at first
there was 150 people Tik Tok continues
to grow watch this how many of you have
no idea who the [__] I am right now
you're just this just showed up and
you're like what the [__] say have no
clue in the comments say have no clue in
the
comments have no there's me see people
don't even
know I know it's a little
blurry see have no clue you saw one in
that I got it all of you should be on
Tik Tok live all of you should be on
Twitch but twitch is harder Tik Tok
gives you Discovery twitch you have to
earn much harder first time from Tik Tok
moonberry all of you on Tik Tok get over
to Twitch right now twitch.tv garbe if
you want to be on the show so this is
inner scorecard who said humil oh
awesome inner let's go in what's inner
can you hear me yes my friend where's
your video listen man I'm on a desktop
that doesn't have a camera I apologize
is that a problem not at all brother I
love your voice first of all love you
tell me the point where you where you
from I'm from California so should I
start telling you how you're wrong or
should you start telling me how I'm
wrong the good news is we're both there
is no right or wrong I actually was more
interested in what your angle or
perspective is on why you believe
humility is overrated like what's what's
your perspective on that because I don't
think it's a right or wrong game I'm
more curious about what your take is
right on listen man I've been following
you for years um I mean I'm a fan I've
been like the last couple years I
haven't been totally in the loop but I
mean you've got it right one thing I
love about you is that you only teach
what you've done so like you don't give
Theory you know what I'm saying like
that's huge and the people that are
listening that's such a good point deal
what's your real name Tom Tom first of
all I knew I kind of like intuitively
liked your comment I love the way you
came on and for your opening line to be
that I really I'm very impressed meaning
thank you for seeing that you're
absolutely right the reason I have so
much conviction and it was funny how I
just was with that young lady and said
this is not a show about making your
long nice or coffee you're absolutely
right bro I'm petrified about talking
[__] I haven't lived because I don't
know the answer unless I did
it thank you for seeing that love it
dude love it um and so like the way I
look at it with humility is overrated I
make a distinction between internal and
external so you were just talking to a
lovely lady who's worried about starting
a podcast right she got five siblings
and what is she worried about being
judged and I see a synonym between being
judged and what did some of those people
say they say who do you think you are
stuff like [__] right who do you think
you are right don't get too big for your
britches they put people in this box of
like be humble don't get to your head
out over your you see what I'm saying
like on the inside internally the more
you know the more you know you don't
know that's a total humility right there
it's but it's sort of paradoxical the
more you know the more you know you
don't so yes you always need to stay
humble on the inside but how do you get
attention how do you put yourself out
there when you can so easily be beat on
the outside with this box of humility
does that make sense very much now I
understand because as you can imagine
words are all contextual so what you're
saying is I love that to your point I'm
such a buyer of that so many people I
believe that the insecure the m one of
my favorite saying I don't use it a lot
I don't bring it up a lot but to your
point this pandemic of misery loves
company is real
the reason to and I fully agree with you
the reason people say to you stay in
your lane who the [__] do you think you
are you're not as good as you think you
are is because that's how they feel
about
themselves so I'm in full agreement
there I think that that if you're using
it in that
context um I don't view I don't view
that as being humble I view that as
being
scared right you know I so understand
the word using and I fully agree I
actually think and I love how you said
that the more you know the more you
don't know that's the whole point of
this for me like I talk with unlimited
levels of
conviction but I also have incredible
capacity to not want to convince people
this is the biggest issue in the world
right now everyone's trying to convince
people to see the world the way they see
it I have no interest in convincing
anyone the way I see it I'm just
convicted about my perspective with the
hope that it brings value to some
people
and so you know I I fully understand
where you're coming from um uh but
that's I I couldn't agree more you're
your point of outside versus inside I
don't even hear people when they say
that thing and I think to your point too
many people living for outside
validation but I actually think one of
the most I think the people that are
most successful oftentimes are either in
extreme insecurity or extreme humility
it drives them you
know let me can I ask you the question
that I've been trying to get through to
you and real quick is let me ask you
this and and I think it might be
somewhat related do you think it's worth
a Leader's time to work on developing
their people's
attitudes I it's yes I do sir as a
matter of fact if you looked at my
schedule the majority of my time as a
CEO and as like someone who leads a lot
of things I would say it's the majority
of what I spend my time on no one can be
remarkable at a task if their emotional
framework is weak even if they're great
at the craft they will crack under the
reality of humans interacting with
humans I find that fascinating dude I
watched when you first rolled out the
stuff with I believe her name is Claude
silver like a lot tremendous tremendous
okay brother I love you for that
question I I I'm fascinated by how many
CEOs spend no time on HR
You' be blown away can I show my C I can
show it to it's a little trick um live I
mean if you saw my calendar my team is
right in front of me they'll tell you
it's like absurd by time I'm I I'm
predominantly spending time on that
because once that's strong you create
continuity you create
retention it it's an incredible thing
when you try to when you give love to
people you get love in return it's very
real yeah I'm glad for that question
thank you brother I knew I wanted you on
here no dude I Vibe with you I've been
messing with you for a long time I'm a
big fan thank you brother thank you for
being on you got it thanks man take care
see you all right let's get more
questions see didn't I intuitively feel
good about that one you had a really
good voice I I agree I was like weirdly
attracted to his voice I was like put
because he didn't show right he didn't
show his face you're like is he cute
right were you guys like is he cute what
are you guys talking like that I was
kind of like is oh that's what I was
thinking all right let's keep it
going
what's up Gary can you hear me I can
Jared how are you first of all Jared I
actually can see certain faces below my
screen that are in the back room I just
want to give you some flowers you're
you're you've been reacting to a lot of
the right stuff and it just makes me
feel warm towards you so some love for
you bro bro love for you see that wine
bottle right
there which one behind you yeah it's
insan oh I see the cute little girl
there yes I see that right there that
bottle's got your uh signature on it I
just bought this girl your book just a
minute ago when you when you said Thank
you thank you brother we're Diamond
holding book hands for the kids and V
friends too and I want to get a heart
Trooper for this one as as soon as we
can vf1 so what's her name Mia Mia such
a pleasure to meet you yeah this is Mia
Ireland so that's actually one of the
things that my question has to do is she
likes to Vlog uh she likes to do baking
stuff kind of Life stuff she does
martial arts Jiu-Jitsu and as a dad I'm
44 she's nine her older sister's 14 into
singing
what where do you go with the the rails
like a bowling alley you know I figured
it's got to have rails of the kids live
streaming the stuff you talk about them
wanting to create brand and content and
what that is for a kid I mean they're
great at playing outside I've got great
these I've got the greatest kids ever
I'm so lucky man um but what where's
your stance on supporting the kids and
all of that that's a great question so a
couple things thanks man by way those
quarter Ray Bor what the [__] dude these
are going to be so great bro I'm so
excited because I've unveiled them
tonight the most fun part of the whole
thing is they're so limited compared to
most be friend stuff this is gonna be
this is gonna be a fun one because
people are not gonna be able to get them
and if they're gonna be mad it's G be a
whole to-do I'm excited about anyway so
um first of all I love talking about
parenting right yeah but I never
never am comfortable ever T telling an
individual parent advice because every
every family every child every sitch is
different that's number one in the
macro I think it's complex I believe
that the concept of of children being
public facing has historical presedent
we're aware that very few child stars
worked out in real life
totally because there's something about
that level of scrutiny and judgment and
money and fame and that is very it's
challenging for us 45 year olds our 38
year olds or 44 year olds or 48 year
olds or 50 year olds seven nine 12 it's
hard on the flip side one could argue
that for a seven or nine or 11 year old
they start to learn it early that
people's comments don't mean anything
and it actually could and so I think it
has something to do
with individuality I believe that if
you're for it and you win the DNA game
and you've done a good job parenting and
the circumstances of the friends and
neighborhood that they grow up in if you
have a wildly confident actually
self-esteemed kid I was one of those I
got terrible grades and even though all
my teachers and all my friends parents
told me I was a loser I didn't believe
them yeah I think I would have done okay
as a 10-year-old with a YouTube channel
talking about baseball cards and people
saying you suck you don't know anything
I would have been okay I think a lot of
people would not be okay and so I think
at the end of the day this is a
individual thing between parents to look
at their children but what they have to
do the entire time is they must make
their children not care about the
subscriptions not care about the likes
not care about the followers and not
care about the positive Andor negative
comments I actually think parents are
good at saying don't worry about the
negative comments I actually think the
bigger thing parents have to teach is
don't listen to the positive comments
love that that's really good because
once she doesn't these two don't get
addicted to the [__] positive
feedback then they become strong I
actually think the positive feedback is
more dangerous than the negative that's
when you get higher known Supply that's
when you get addicted to the feedback
that's when you get addicted to the love
of the audience's feelings about you
that is the
vulnerability that's so
good you get that yes yeah definitely
all right Gary you're the man you're the
man love you brother good D love you see
you good stuff I [__] love this show
already this is a real problem I got
real I have this is when I do my big boy
meetings my seven to my 7 to 10 PMS are
like really important work time for me
if I get addicted with this show it's a
problem [__]
but this is it the Q&A shows everything
there she is hi Gary great to see you
it's nice to see you again but it
doesn't matter how many times I talk to
you I get nervous every time even in
Chicago at Macy's even at Chicago at the
baseball card show even on Zoom right
now yes well that's extremely
flattering I'm gonna do this one I'm
gonna get one more in and I want to be
spontaneous from the chat from a
question right now now right to the show
go ahead I don't think no you're not
going to be able to see this see I'm not
good with this stuff but um I put on the
mirror my for in my daughter's room love
yourself first love yourself most I put
those messages on there so that was the
one for today so I thought that was
great I love um so my question is I run
a very tiny nonprofit it's a it's a
youth dance group when I first started
it the whole my mission statement was um
to continue teaching traditional Mexican
dance so it doesn't die out in our area
that's cool so I've lived here outside
of Chicago in Porter County Indiana
since 1977 when we moved here so okay
fast forward through the years there was
still no dance group of that kind in my
County they're all in Chicago okay so I
had a daughter so I went ahead and um I
started my own group even though I
really didn't know what I was doing um
but it's been 10 years later and now my
mission has changed and because I'm very
small I you know can't qualify for grant
funding or things like that so my
mission went from okay teaching kids
traditional dance and discipline
teamwork all that stuff but now it has
turned into
something a lot with a lot more meaning
to me I've had kids come through that
have survived abuse
that have survived um just grief from
losing a grandparent and I'm going to
try not to get emotional but like I had
one girl um she was eight years old and
she came up to me and she's like you
know I don't think I'm going to be happy
anymore and I said why and she said
because my Grandpa died and that's why
her mom had actually brought her back to
the group because you know life gets in
the way
and and most recently I had a a family
that the kids were climbing out a window
to escape domestic abuse okay and so now
my mission is I want a place for these
kids to be normal to have fun so you
know teaching the traditional dance has
taken um yeah it's escapism it's you
just want a safe place for people that
are
struggling yes exactly
and so my question
is the way I'll get funding like cuz we
put on a show every year we've been
doing it for 10 years and by the way the
person who started that that I had to
help with that is your buddy is it Todd
Kaplan from Pepsi yes he doesn't know
that well I mean I told him I did tell
him um when I saw him at vcon but you
know I'm sure he has a bunch of projects
but he did the Pepsi refresh project one
year for the Super Bowl and to get
funding you had to do voting on Facebook
and that's the only reason I even got on
Facebook so with with that Pepsi funding
we were able to get costumes and
everything but anyway um how do I ask
like a bank or a business or an
insurance agent how would I get a
request for a sponsorship or for funding
to how much you how much are you looking
for oh I mean it can be anything like
you know we'll ask for $200 you know do
$1,000 you know I I don't think that's
the other thing I'm very bad at asking
for help let alone money well then if
you're bad at that you're going to be
bad at it
okay but I'm trying to change see that's
why I'm yeah I'm asking how how by
asking I stand out though from everyone
else there is no stand out there is no
stand
out okay you know there's little leagues
and cheerleading and everybody I'm aware
of the millions of little organizations
in every town on in America that are
looking for funding for the things
they're passionate about I've
heard the way you do it is by asking
but I guess what like what's the focus
like for me my focus is I like you said
I want the kids to have a safe space so
is that more important than saying oh
we're a youth dance group teaching
traditional Mexican dance well if I'm
somebody who has Mexican heritage and my
grandma who is my favorite person love
to dance for me it's going to matter
that you do Mexican
dance if you're if but if I'm the CEO of
a local business or that or some sort of
high net worth individual or what have
you and the number one person in my life
was my mother and I lost my mother and
you said I'm here for people to be able
to escape the traumas of their
day-to-day then when you said that that
would trigger me the answer is there is
no right answer there's just a right
answer for individual people you don't
know the answer until you ask the
question
okay all right well that that do you
have a
GoFundMe uh no I think you
should usually I'll ask um on Facebook
and again like I said pushing myself out
of my comfort zone they do those
birthday you know requests for Facebook
and I wasn't going to do it because I
don't like you know asking my friends
for money but I did so it raised
$700 and I wasn't going to do it so I
was excited about that so how about this
is this an actual nonprofit yeah it's a
501c3
amazing why don't so you said 700 you
got on Facebook yeah for my birthday
fundraiser okay good I've decided right
here on the spot that I'm gonna give you
10 times more than
that don't make me
cry that's amazing thank you so much cuz
we have we're having our our annual show
that we're preparing for that comes up
um in the fall for Hispanic Heritage
Month and I even this year we or at the
end of last year we started even with
senior citizens I had an 87 year old
lady asked me why don't you give classes
for people my age she's right and I said
find give me find four more people and
I'll do it and we did and I was
surprised even at the need for you know
senior citizens that watch how much how
much did you raise last year for
this um I because of things that were
happening at home and yeah I'm not I'm
not worried about don't hedg it just
tell me how much well I guess my point
is I didn't really ask because I'm not
that wasn't the question how much did
you raise um $4 400
4,000 as far as sponsorships I don't
think it was more than not including if
you take out my birthday fundraiser I
don't think it was more than 500 great
and then and you made 700 birthday so
you made 1,200 bucks last year yeah and
today you decided to jump on this stream
give awareness to it and I just gave you
7,000 my
[Applause]
God thank
you you're
welcome I don't I that's not even enough
I don't know what to say yeah you don't
have to say anything I'm happy to do it
I've I've met you multiple multiple
multiple times I like your daughter very
much by the way I think she's sharp I I
caught her uh I caught her watching your
the um vriends opening they were opening
the cards I told I cat it random times
she's always doing that I told you she
was smart and you know what I have to
tell you the last time I talked to you I
said because of um vcon she decided to
pursue
nursing and then but then and I couldn't
put my finger finger on why I couldn't
picture her as a nurse like I just never
saw that but I didn't say anything
because I couldn't figure it out
recently she said mom don't get mad at
me and I said what and she said I
changed my pathway I'm not going into
nursing and I said okay and I said why
she said I want to take care of people
like the elderly she works in a nursing
home right now she said I want to take
care of people I don't like the medicine
part I have no desire to learn anything
about medicine and I was like that's it
I said that's why I couldn't picture her
I was thinking to myself as a nurse so
she I was proud of her I said good then
don't said you want to be a caregiver
and you don't want to do the nursing
part that's fine so I was just glad that
she um figured that out for herself
people are asking for the name of the
charity do you have anywhere to send
people oh gosh it's in Spanish and I
don't know where I can I'm going to put
it here in this chat um Facebook can you
can you please create a
GoFundMe
um yes okay thank
you
NWI um so I put it on the back in this
backstage thing I don't know he's got it
he'll figure it out all right I want to
sneak one more in I got to be in a
meeting in one minute and it's a four
minute walk so I'm already in trouble
thank you so much for your positivity
and for being friends and for everything
you have info we'll get that taken care
of we'll get that to Nate schroer
in the foundation you'll take care of it
you have $7,000
now all I need is you with the show
now nobody I know no probably only one
person knows who you are because those
are that's just not they don't they
don't I just gave you $7,000 why you
dissing me no I'm not I'm I'm kiding I'm
joking I'm joking I'm
joking that's just not their I'm joking
I'm joking there's 8 billion people on
Earth 7.9 billion have no [__] clue
who I am I'm thrilled let's keep it
moving all right quick do you have
something or
no questions that are safe no you know
what actually I can't be late for this
this is an employee I got to do HR I
love you I hope you enjoyed the show Tik
Tock I [__] with you now I'm hanging up
on you uh twitch I love you feel free
after I'm done with the show hang out
with each other tell me if you want me
to do this again thank you for coming
out we'll do it again I love you I hope
you enjoyed it
[Music]